[Music]
today of course is a huge day in the
world of technology Apple hosted a live
keynote event at which they introduced
the Apple iPhone 6 and the new Apple
watch now I love those Apple product
debut videos they show them every time
and I think I love them because of the
music check this out
[Music]
yeah amazing well we're very lucky is
tonight because tonight we have the
composure of all the music Apple uses in
their product videos please welcome all
the way from Munich Germany pianist
yen's Mueller
[Applause]
you probably remember yen's music for
the very first iPhone debut a bunch of
years ago yen's
[Music]
yes and who could forget yet who could
forget the ends composition for the
launch of Apple's first iPad
[Music]
[Applause]
well here's the piece yen's premiered
for today's launch of the Apple watch
[Music]
that's why I've asked them to write an
original composition to accompany my
announcement of tonight's guests that's
right our first guest tonight the
hilarious aunt of Paris
[Applause]
if she the star of the CBS series mom
she also has a standby battery life
hooked to 16 days and she can charge
wirelessly in less than one hour next
actor comedian and author John Hodgman
John futures ain't 100% anodized
aluminum casing it's water resistant up
to 30 meters plus he can hold up to four
hours of full HD video finally we have
Wiz Khalifa
which contains over 2 billion nano
transistors in his hands by the
revolutionary AAA processor making the
most technologically advanced musical
guest available a lot more show coming
up we'll be right back yet and play us
out
you
you